this is breaking news on
8 news now 5 30 on a tuesday morning
we've been covering this all morning
long metro police say
one of its own officers shot and killed
someone this morning in the southwest
valley
happened around 1 30 this morning inside
the spanish hills neighborhood that's
near tropicana and durango
bianca holman is live on scene with new
details from metro hi bianca what can
you tell us
good morning alex good morning john you
know this is a neighborhood that has
million dollar homes you can see it is
gated they have holiday decorations out
there
and the patrol cars that are out there
right now they just turned off their
lights but at the entrance there are
still
metro vehicles in front now there was a
and a home security system that alerted
police to this burglary
in progress we told we were told that
there were two people inside the home
when a man broke in
metro police briefed us on the details
once they arrived
as officers arrived on scene and
approached the house they could see the
suspect inside the house
officers made entry into the house and
immediately saw the suspect
armed with a hammer attempting to attack
the homeowner
officers fired their weapons and the
suspect was struck
you can hear that's a pretty scary
situation for those two victims
and uh when the police when the
ambulance the police called the
ambulance and when the ambulance arrived
they pronounced the suspect a man dead
now this is the 18th involved officer
involved shooting of 2020 here for metro
and um they also tell us that no
officers were injured during this
situation
however in the next 72 hours we should
also get another briefing from the
sheriff
or a representative and also they'll be
releasing that body camera footage that
the officers were wearing when they
responded to this situation
reporting live the oklahoman eighteen's
now